ça allait pouvoir gagner 200 euros
xavier pas si tu les gardes tu sais pas
si c'est pas tout les gars je ne joue
pas pour 200 euros non connais pas
tarder à vous énerver gagnent champion
du jour coco il va tous vous défier s'il
vous bat tous la personne qu'on a en
ligne gagne aura 200 euros s'il perd
d'ailleurs non c'est l'inversé
exactement s'il perd la personne en
ligne dure à 200 euros s'il gagnera 300
euros demain dans la cagnotte
c'est bien sûr le beau battre c'est
parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
recours et les cherry on a quelqu'un au
leem qui va jouer avec nous il y aura
des questions vous allez jouer bien sûr
en même temps et il vous a essayé
d'aimer tout le monde non qu il d'accord
ça va être des questions sur l'activité
des questions musicales on a beaucoup
varié aujourd'hui je pense que vous
allez bien vous amuser avec nous à léa
on a en a quelques uns en ligne pour
jouer avec nous allô allô allô allô on
et comment sur le téléphone tous les
soirs bien ok oui allô oui allô allô oui
bonjour monsieur bonjour oui allô oui
bonjour qu'est comment vous appelez
saviez comment l'aviez xavier c'est
exagéré ou saffier javier ça les xavier
bonjour de servier
tanguay s'est pas quoi casser la paix
pour la borne en matinée affecté à tarek
tabaka x m'ont dit xavier rappelle que
le sol est en délire comme ça vient on
ne peut pas et on peut pas tomber sur
une seule paire normal nous aurions
benoît et sur un gars normal xavier tu
nous a beaucoup manqué vous manque et je
n'ai pas choisi mon prénom
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous appelez donc saffier l'est angers
sens de l'ironie mme je m'en fous car je
suis fan de vous malgré le patron des
chantiers nous appeler ou que ça fier
d'alsace à strasbourg
j'habite exactement être amené fils a
fait beaucoup d'émules tellement on vous
laissez moi parler
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ce gaz est de relever la parole à des
auditeurs à des téléspectateurs et y
aient l'humilité de les laisser
s'exprimer au nom de tous les gens grâce
à quitter
ça fait combien d'accord avec ça dit
edmond merci xavier en tout cas d'être
là de l'autre d'avoir soi cela tout est
malade
oui c'est vrai ça fier que sa fille et
sa fille est ce que vous les joies des
fermes ta gueule
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sortie mais ça vient ça vient mais c'est
vrai oui oui je la honte mot compellent
marrant parce qu'à côté de patrick
énervé le le bis trouve retard comme et
que saviez vous allez jouer
rien n'est plus que jamais xavier lavier
danser aviez lavier ouais ouais ouais
bon ok alors oui que j'explique ça allez
pouvoir gagner 200 euros xavier pas si
tu les gardes s'est passé c'est petit
l'égard des gardes
chen zhu pets du rhône on connait pas
tarder à vous énerver gagne sentiers oui
sa pièce que je te propose c'est qu'on
joue ensemble dans quelques minutes tu
restes avec nous se retrouve dans un
instant d'accord xavier ok ça m'a déjà
coûté 200 balles de téléphone tout y est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a également une personne au téléphone
qui va soirée contre caux et cette
personne c'est que sa fille est avec
nous tu as attendu de saint ciers
alors oui que sa fille était toujours là
ouais je suis toujours là ça fait quand
même deux plombes du mal à cerner qui
sait tous préféré dans l'équipe s'en
foutent à me taper la pub les chansons
il nous appelait pourquoi tu énervé
comme ça tu t'es fait larguer par ta
main pourquoi je suis gay
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors comme les chapelles ton fiancé
matches où tu es sur ton fiancé
s'appelle pas à came back i'll c'est
plutôt mon amoureux du moment
ah ouais on amoureux du moment ouais
ouais pourquoi c'est clair que ça fier
oui d'accord saffier tepa sur m6 tous
l'arrêt oui oui à 21h en direct pour le
spectacle ouais exactement ces gars des
[Applaudissements]
bons gars des bons gars merci vous avez
montré au on voulait aux boulettes abord
je voulais absolument ta bonté et cauna
mans ce soir en tout cas incendiés en
tout cas en tout cas en tout cas je suis
très très content dans quelques instants
on va les stèles en direct de ces eaux
là je suis dans ma loge c'est avec qui
je suis en détente avec qui avec karine
le marchand
non c'est ta tête tu vas là-bas karine
sa maman chérie
battez pas dans le prétoire
j'ai très vite aimé ça va mais ma chérie
écart innovation c'est quand même sympa
et basculer les élections donc merci
karine bravo car il
[Musique]